I would actually be delighted to but you
know I was homeless done I'm poor handle
so that period huh and and I'm very
thankful to have the opportunity to be
here the Simon's Institute all right so
um one of my students here has done a
lot of the ideas that weren't to present
here so I just want to give credit to
these people here I'm going to talk
about two problems here first of all we
want to minimize a smooth objective
function when derivatives are not
available problem number one is
derivative free optimization I have
observed people developing methods for
this problem throughout the years I
don't think I've ever given a talk about
this subject derivative free
optimization I didn't deliver observing
people develop methods and there are
some things that are missing I want to
develop methods are scalable into that
like a thousand variables I want to be
sure that the algorithm is parallel why
can't we do parallel function
evaluations in these algorithms and I
want to use the information that I have
from function values to create something
better than linear models but I don't
want to create something what Katya
called fully quadratic model if you ever
attempt to do a fully quadratic model
it's gonna not gonna be scalable that's
what like lay claim that I will make now
you evaluate functions right you're
gonna have to know how to evaluate how
to place the evaluations of the
functions efficiently I think it's going
to be key and how to do this after we
look at the deterministic problem of
derivative free optimization then we're
going to say what happens if there's
noise in the function I would like to
use the same approach and the key of
this is to use some noise estimation
techniques our classical numerical
analysis deal or gold back to Hamming in
the 1960s so if I have a noisy function
and I want to minimize it the first one
thing I want to do is estimate the level
of noise with that level of noise I'm
going to be able to get a finite
difference interval to do finite
difference grading approximations so in
this talk we're actually going to fall
back and say how do I know how to create
quadratic models that I know how to
solve in a scalable way and after trying
everything else I see that the only way
I know how to do that is going back to
quasi Newton methods so we're gonna go
and do quasi Newton methods would find
any differences in the noisy case
something that people have considered to
be very risky thing to do and in order
to do that we're gonna have to be
adaptive we cannot make definitive
decisions of what the noise is or what
the finite difference intervals are the
algorithm have to find out when they
make a mistake go back and correct what
they are doing but we're already able to
solve problems a thousands of variables
derivative free optimization problem no
no problem whatsoever with or without
noise now I'll present only one
convergence result in this talk this
talk is going to be mainly algorithmic
I'm going to present one convergence
result to a neighborhood of the solution
so what do I want an optimization for
noisy functions to do I wanted to go to
a neighborhood of the solutions they
turn by the noise level and I want to
show that I can converge to that quickly
linearly
now before I start everybody keeps
making reference to the very first talk
in this symposium by Alexander where he
talked about how far should I trust my
model right so I'm going to go and talk
about something else I'm going to talk
about non smooth optimization and why we
were quite surprised there about the
power of course in Newton updating all
right so suppose that I want to minimize
the absolute value function and I want
to use a quasi Newton algorithm to do
that now I'm gonna be very precise with
Ben about what is the definition of the
quasi Newton algorithm because it will
be very important in this concept okay
so it's a model right any iteration that
looks like this it's coming from a
quadratic model of the objective
function so we're going to do non smooth
optimization by creating quadratic
models of the objective function doesn't
it sound like the wrong idea
right so in Alexander's talk says I
cannot trust my model beyond this point
it's not valid anymore right so what
would be a Newton model of this function
in this area it's a straight line right
so it should not move beyond that line
and in fact the observation of Lewis
and/or Burton is that the reason
quasi-newton methods work is because
they're always to force to look beyond
the kink right the problem in non smooth
optimization is that you make a guess of
how the objective function looks like
and suddenly probably you get a surprise
right suddenly there is non smoothness
and it throws you off what is a way to
solve this problem getting thrown off by
a kink well one way to do it is always
make sure if there is a kink to go
through that kink so that you observe
the objective function before and after
the kink if you do that then you can
create a smoothing model about that and
things will work okay so if you apply a
quasi Newton classical BFGS with no
changes whatsoever and the way they're
implemented to minimize a non smooth
function like this it will work it will
get very close to the solution and the
reason for this is if you start here
whatever model it is of the objective
function it kind of tell you to move
this way but now the lionsearch is the
key right in quasi-newton method that
tells you you know whenever you move
from here to here it's not enough to
have reduced the objective function the
the gradient the directional derivative
the objective function has to increase
so don't stop the line search until the
derivative has increased right the
derivative here is constant so if you
the algorithm tells you to move this way
even though you have decreased the
objective function a lot it tells you do
not stop until this derivative has
changed means the function is forcing
you to go over here so if you start at
this point here the quasi-newton step
will go over there now what's the
definition of a quasi Newton method it's
a hermit interpolated
the model here is going to interpolate
the two gradients plus a function value
and it's going to do something else yet
something else is the difference between
BFGS and other methods but it will
return for like these two malls and
it'll create a quadratic model like that
it will take a step then it will move
this way and the line search will force
it to cross every time we will for
to cross every time we will create a
quadratic model that is steeper and
steeper this is a very simple problem in
one dimension is going to get you to the
solution The Matrix is gonna blow up and
everything is gonna work but let me
explain that a little bit more in detail
right so if you apply the BFGS method
with the right line search which is what
is in the textbooks then lewis and
overturn and more recently Frank Curtis
have found out that that's more
effective than all the arguments that
have been developed for non general non
smooth optimization like bundle methods
more effective and by a wide margin what
we call the wolf line search ensures
that you always create a convex model of
the objective function this is one of
the secrets of course in Newton up daily
the line search tells you that you have
to do that now not smooth but not smooth
problems usually have derivatives almost
everywhere so you apply the algorithm as
if there are no kinks and there may be
some little things that you have to do
in hay in case you hit one of them now
the line search requires you have a
decrease Armijo condition and what I
called the curvature condition this
Wolfe condition says the directional
derivative has to have to should
increase and this is the textbook
picture how things look like right so
the key in making a quasi Newton
algorithm work for non smooth problems
is that when you do the line search you
should not stop anywhere here just
because you have reduced the objective
function you should not stop here you
should wait until do it until the
directional derivative has increased
somewhat right where has it increased
somewhat well depending on what the
parameter is maybe it's here so if I
have this gradient and that gradient
that admits it convicts a nice convex
model and that's going to allow me to
take a step every question you can
update says do that otherwise it is not
well-defined
and things are gonna work there all
right so this is an empirical
observation by Luis and over to an
applied course in Newton algorithms to
non smooth problems and another
empirical observation is that if you
look at the BFGS matrix when you
converge it has actually captured the UV
structure of the objective function so
some functions that are not smooth
our non-smooth in some direction and
smooth and another direction and you
will see that the Hessian approximation
actually has captured that it's blown up
in one of the directions and in the
other one it maintains the right
curvature this is observed empirically
now as you convert to the solution they
has it if the if there is a
discontinuity non smoothness at the
solution then the Hessian approximation
will blow up right and that's a good
thing because you're making you're
reproducing these kinks and the
objective functions but there's almost
no theory in explaining that I have
never heard of anybody seen a failure
when applying the BFGS method to solve a
non smooth optimization problem and
people not been trying for many years
nobody has observed a failure so
therefore one should be able to prove a
result they're very limited results in
one dimension for very special functions
some of us have tried really hard and
Steve was telling me there a lot of
recover for your additions in this
building one needs a very clever
theoretician to work through that theory
and try to determine if this is really
true right for what classes of functions
will this algorithm work is too much of
a coincidence that it's always working
fine okay
the power of the armijo-wolfe condition
is not appreciated in the convex
optimization community because it is not
that important that convex optimization
community in general right but just to
go back to Steve's negative curvature
case if you have a non convex problem if
you start doing it a line search and the
function looks concave you should keep
going
right the Wolfe lionsearch says do not
stop until the derivative has increased
when will that happen all you have to
assume is that the function is bounded
below and the term bounded below has
been mentioned here several times or
what you need actually to for the
convergence of BFGS is that the function
is smooth and bounded below right so you
observe that for non convex functions if
you have a non convex function doing a
Wolfe line search produces
regularizer a quadratic approximation of
the model but not an ester of type /
estimator
it's a hermit interplant right and that
can be a lot more powerful right
so / estimators are great for
establishing convergence results because
you know that everything is for sure
these are actually sort of tailor
approximations to the function but with
the understanding that you have gone far
enough to make the interpolation you had
a question was unclear to me about the
luminescent Overton paper is whether or
not it's BFGS or the line search that
gives you the good behavior for example
the absolute value you just do steepest
descent and you do the Wolfe line search
you get linear convergence and there are
other cases that were that also is true
for the steepest descent it works we're
talking about where they're crossing
Newton works right Overton paper is safe
or not smooth quasi Newton works well
are meet bracketing line search yeah
yeah if you just do pick the minimum
norm subgrade with just just do this
line search
you also get rapid convergence on these
non smooth problems yeah and my
statement is any of those methods that
you produce with sub gradients we're
gonna kill you with a question using the
method so show me one of them and you're
going to see how these sub gradient
methods are blind right so you have a
sub grade but you don't know how far to
move you do because it forces you over
the king oh yeah okay all right so good
the line search okay so that was the
point what happens if you do a line
search with a oh no but that's gonna be
a problem no I believe there's a lot of
search has a lot of juice but you need
to reproduce the UV structure because if
you have not learned you're gonna make
the same mistake you're gonna come and
repeat and make the same mistake right
so once you have near kink you're gonna
have to stay near the kink and a purely
gradient method is not going to learn
that so you do need to learn the UV
structure so thanks for that question
that's where the power is going to be
all right that was not supposed to be
the subject of my talk just some
propaganda here about we we've been
surprised about the power of course in
Newton updating in context where it was
not defined to work okay so it continues
to surprise us a leading method for non
structure non smooth optimization it's
actually a great approach for doing
derivative free optimization where there
is no noise it actually competes very
well almost anything and in this talk we
claim that finite difference quasi
newton approximation when done in an
adaptive way actually it's also should
be leaning approach for doing derivative
free optimization of noisy functions let
me first review and make a few
commentaries on the methodology that
katya went and described right what is
one way of doing derivative free
optimization you sample the functions
you create a model by interpolation you
minimize the model that's the new step
you remove a point at a new point repeat
the process so by interpolation you can
construct that model and in order to get
a quadratic approximation to the
function you need or the order of N
squared function evaluations right
that's a lot now powell came up with
some idea where you only need to
interpolate endpoints and use a minimum
Frobenius norm update but the arithmetic
costs of these algorithms is still very
high I don't think it can be below into
the fourth and what happens is that
you're creating a dense model everywhere
of the objective form you're using
interpolation points where you put the
interpolation point is important because
of course you can't do high dimensional
interpolation if all the points are in
the line you get an ill-conditioned
interpolant now this is a theoretical
problem I don't know how important it is
in practice but that it can happen is a
concern right now that there's a trust
region in solving this problem that's
good
that's natural that helps you actually
control things but can these methods be
made to paralyze
and I don't know if they can be made to
paralyse I know that people have done
that but what I'm going to describe here
pal arises in a completely natural way
yes reduce rotational force my daughter
or or whatever these guys get and you
know get the Nena exact solution to the
quadratic model just you know do some
clever sampling so you want to create
the same model but so we're in exactly
right
I don't know how to do that it's all
system of linear equations you can
definitely solve it an exactly but then
but then I actually want to comment this
end to the fourth is is only if you were
trying to do really accurate
second-order models right otherwise
whatever number of points you so it
doesn't have to be able to the fourth so
number of samples some curvature let's
not call it accurate quadratic model
they call it let's call it interpolant
based quadratic model purely was a
Newton after all right yeah so if you're
trying to was a Newton after certain
number of proper rational approximation
is gonna have something approximate so
it's similar in that sense and I think
you were not here when you and you said
I do not want to do that I I don't think
it's you can answer with a scalable
method if you try to get a model that
tries to interpolate the function
everywhere right so let me hold on your
question how about if I go to the next
slide when we contrast the two
approaches we've not written a paper and
we have a long discussion of the pros
and cons about these two approaches so
can it paralyze can you decrease the
cost and so on well let's see those are
open questions but what happens if you
do find a difference is so there's no
noise here I'm just talking about just
doing standard stuff right are you so
you approximate the derivative by finite
differences you spend in function
evaluations just to do any move right so
that's a significant cost but then how
do you construct the quadratic model you
just say BFGS give me that model right
there every iteration I'm giving you
gradients give me the model and the good
thing about this is that well the
difference is we're interpolating
gradients and not functions this is a
very important distinction the two
different approaches I think we can do
the linear algebra cost and O n work
because we know how to do limited memory
quasi Newton updating and that's a very
low cost so the last thing that is gonna
worry me now is the arithmetic cost the
placement
of where the function evaluations is
done because it's finite differences is
going to be forced to do an orthogonal
set so they're going to be spread out by
definition the points were used but not
for interpolation the points for
producing a gradient now the grain
contains a lot of information now there
is no possibility of you for creating
ill conditioning like when you have
interpolation because BFGS is an
overriding process so therefore if you
do something and then you do something
in it's contradictory the last piece of
information over writes the last one so
provided you do the right wolf line
search this is going to be a stable
process and if this method paralyzed is
quite easily during the evaluation of
the gradients right so I'm not saying
one is better than the other one I'm
trying to put some things together and
then maybe we can wrap up at the end to
see what is fair and what is not fair
now why am I talking about this now when
this is nothing but taking as an old
code and doing finite difference
approximations why are we talking about
this now I think there was a perception
for a long time to doing n function
evaluations just to do one step is
wasteful and rarely in the literature of
derivative free optimization do people
say well let me compare with finite
difference quasi Newton updating it's
almost never done right so otherwise we
would have detected throughout the years
are the two things work but why is this
not new because tons of people are
already doing derivative free
optimization via crosstie newton
updating for instance if you go to
matlab you say well here's an objective
function you don't give the gradient say
it's smooth
Matta will do fine any difference is
costing util and that's the way it will
solve the problem and that's the same
thing that our software nitro will do
and so on so nothing of this what I said
here is new this has been done before
there is always the risk and choosing
the finite difference interval because
the second derivative estimate is always
there things can go a little bit bad the
only question is whether it's
competitive right and that's where we
spend a little time doing some tests and
I'm going to skip this because I'm
running behind you know the our
numerical experiments say if you do a
model based trust treat trust region
methods or if you do
as a finite difference question isn't
updating in terms of function
evaluations they're comparable in terms
of arithmetic cost it is way cheaper to
do the quasi-newton approach and we're
solving today problems in thousands of
variables no problem whatsoever right so
there you have those two things fine
that part is boring crossing it and
updating can you really do it with noisy
functions so that's the subject of this
don't look at that graph that's the
subject of this talk here so suppose now
you have an objective function and that
has additive noise or maybe
multiplicative noise and that's supposed
to day that what we have is and the
objective function is the sum of a
smooth function plus some additive noise
and the additive noise is going to be
bounded and the only assumption we're
gonna make and the question is how do
you do a find a difference BFGS method
well our approach is the following first
you're going to invest some function
evaluations in estimating the noise it's
going to be the noise is going to be a
standard deviation of this function here
you're going to spend some effort
estimating the noise that will give you
a finite difference interval it
shouldn't be too small otherwise noise
shouldn't be too large non-linearity
then you take a step you work with the
algorithm unless something goes bad the
noise is the measure we're going to use
is not one of these super expensive
sample average approximations there's
gonna be some randomized approach if it
fails and the line sir is gonna tell you
if it fails there's gonna be a
corrective approach and it's going to
say what what do you got wrong did you
go to noise estimate wrong or were you
unlucky with the line search and it will
do something about that so we'll need to
modify the line search and then of
course if you have a noisy function it
is clear that the choice of the finite
difference interval is crucial right so
if it's too small you're differentiating
noise and the algorithm will really
break down it's gonna be a terrible
algorithm right and if the finite
difference interval is too large then of
course the grain is not accurate enough
so you're gonna have to do that
correctly alright so the definition of
the noise that we're going to estimate
is
the standard deviation of this quantity
here we're going to denote by epsilon F
what we detect is the noise and then how
is this estimated so this is a procedure
of moria and wild I don't know how well
known it is here we have found it to be
extremely effective it does the
following I'm at a point X I want to
know what the noise level of the
function is choose a random Direction
evaluate the function at say eight
points at spacing of say ten to the
minus two and then produce a finite
difference table as follows
that's math as as follows so I have the
function I evaluated at seven different
points zero is the base point and ten to
the minus two I evaluate the function at
those points there then you take the
difference in the function values and
then you take the differences of the
differences and you continue that way
now you don't take the differences and
divide them by H you just take the
differences right so these quantities
here if f is a smooth function and I
start taking more and more differences
to that these quantities should go to
zero in fact the second one should go to
zero like h squared and so on if they
don't go to zero is because there's
noise and taking differences from noise
will actually be constant now if you
take enough differences you'll be able
to detect the level of noise now in the
previous slide I jumped there was a
formula for how do you use this table to
detect the noise level and this Sigma K
is your estimate the standard deviation
here we're after every finite difference
we're getting an estimate what the noise
level is for this problem this is the
original problem the noise was ten to
the minus three times that right so if
you look at this table of finite
differences you see that the noise level
is being estimated fairly quickly
through
the finite differences approach but
there is an observation that Maury and
Wilde made that is a really good and
that is the one that one whenever
there's a change in sign you should
realize that you're there
you've already detected the noise right
so how could it be that I'm making
differences here and suddenly there's a
change in sign this is because the noise
is beginning to dominate right this is
already a level in which you probably
are pretty comfortable are taking the
finite differences now just to be clear
how expensive is to do this noise
estimation well we did six extra
function evaluations and all these
differences are for free right you just
compute differences of function so you
can do all of them
you extract from that the noise estimate
and from that you're going to get a
formula for the derivative so this is
the formula that tells you how to get an
estimate of the noise based on the
finite difference table and their
convergence results about this all right
so once you have an estimate of the
noise the finite difference interval for
forward differences is given by this and
for central difference is given like
that and this is the I faith Emidio to
everybody who's been America analysis
this is what you got you get when you
this is round of error the square root
of Machine epsilon is what you do here
you get the square root of the noise and
there is always a turn the second
derivative term this third derivative
term and often people say well that's
one or maybe we'll have to estimate it
right so if you have to estimate it is
going to be extra work you have to we
really want to be really careful you
will do that all right so I'm gonna
present this algorithm
looks too boring but it's not so bad
here it is give me a starting point I
take a random direction evaluate the
function six times and estimate the
noise boom compute the finite difference
interval forward differences compute an
estimate of the gradient that takes you
and function evaluations then compute a
quasi Newton step classical no change
whatsoever and then you do a line search
this is BFGS so we're gonna do an Army
who a wolf line search we're gonna try
to get those two conditions and there
are two possibilities it worked
let's forget about this block if the
noisy line search worked why should I
reject it I'll take the point I look at
the curvature pairs if the line search
worked this quantity here is positive I
can add that to the memory of limited
memory and continue so the only
difficult case is what happens if in the
line search I have trouble and what do I
mean by trouble in the line search we're
going to do the line search but we're
gonna limit ourselves to how many
attempts are going to do and we're gonna
relax it in some way if the line search
works it does not work then we're gonna
have a recovery procedure right so you
have an album that is estimating finite
differences and suddenly it fails there
are two possibilities you estimated the
noise wrong in this case why don't you
reactivate the noise the other one it
looks like the estimate of the noise is
fine the finite difference interval is
fine maybe just the lionsearch set you
off confused you so in that case just
produce some other move by some means
that's more or less the the description
of the recovery procedure which I think
I just mentioned here and I think
there's no point in getting into those
details right
maybe I should I maybe I shouldn't get
into that
maybe I should stop here and just try to
shoot down my algorithm yes cutting it's
not comparison with implicit filtering
what happens is that I was going to use
my hands instead of these slides let me
try to describe again what the recovery
procedure is we're going to use a
stencil when it this is where Kelly's
ideas come from from is from a stencil
right okay so if the algorithm succeeded
fine if during the line search I have
trouble I'm going to do two things first
of all I realize at the starting point I
did a finite difference approximation to
the gradient I evaluated the function n
times right how about if I store the
lowest function value that I saw during
the finite difference approximation and
I'm going to call that F sub s and
that's what appears here I'm going to
keep that as a reference point so then
what is the procedure going to do first
of all something wrong happened
therefore we estimate the noise but
don't be estimated along the random
Direction estimate the noise along the
search Direction where you're moving so
do those six extra function evaluations
to get a new noise level and then you
find a difference interval then compare
then you find a difference interval with
the one you were using if they were
similar then you're going to do some
things look good if they don't look
similar then you have to re s tomato
noise right but so if they don't look
similar then you take the new estimate
of the finite difference interval and
you get out of there right otherwise you
take a tiny perturbation just say
everything looked good I'm going to
perturb the function and then I'm going
to see here certain tests right so I
perturb the function a little bit and I
see is it better than the all the points
that I saw under stencil in that case I
should take it otherwise if the points
in the stands
so gives you a sufficient decrease I'm
taking a point in the stencil because
actually that's going to drive a
convergence theory pattern search method
theory is gonna drive you that so
there's going to be a backup mechanism
that will work in the deterministic case
in the noisy case it's not clear not
clear all right but that's roughly the
idea of what you do you really meet the
noise and so on and the details are
aren't be I'm not completely there all
right so the line search
so you attempt to satisfy the
armijo-wolfe line search and we know
that this is always possible in the
deterministic case if the function is
smooth and bounded below but if there's
noise this can be problematic in
particular if you estimated your
gradient poorly it may not even be a
descent direction for your underlying
smooth function right so it may be try
to do a pointless or line search right
so the line search strategy is going to
be to limit the number of attempts you
do to try to satisfy the armijo-wolfe
conditions if you cannot do it in five
points then you do the following
you're gonna relax the Armijo condition
by the level of noise that you have
there and you're gonna try to attempt to
solve our mijo wolf wolf is very
important that you have because you need
the curvature condition so that so this
is the way the line search is being
attempted to be satisfied and you have
three possible outcomes you satisfy the
possibly relaxed Armijo condition I mean
her wolf condition only Armijo condition
is satisfied or none of them is
satisfied right and in fact in order to
get the album to be effective we accept
a point that satisfies their miho
condition but if it doesn't satisfy the
wolf condition then the pair's cannot go
into the course in you can update that's
the only restriction that there is right
so those three cases are they're
differentiated and here's a couple of
numerical results we have done tons and
tons of numerical results and these ones
I will explain what do we have here the
number of function evaluations and this
is the gap between the objective
function and the optimal value these are
simple problems for which you know the
exact value of the objective function
and what we're trying here is a code
that Katya gave us I think it was
written with with riche we sent a I mean
it's a prototype code it's not too
sophisticated this or the other one this
is a model based trust region algorithm
right and I don't think it has any
special features for noise right we just
use it like that and certainly injecting
noise and the method was remarkably
robust with respect to noise it was
working well and it started you know
generating only when the noise was very
high right and then you have a finite
difference and a central difference
approximation to the gradients and what
do we see well we see variability of
results right but and for instance in
this particular case the other ones are
you know sort of competitive in terms of
function evaluations then the trust
region method finds itself in a
situation where it's adjusting the trust
region one problem about the way the
code is written is that if the trust
region becomes too small it has no
option to make it bigger because once
your trouble you make it smaller right
and so when there's noise in the
objective function it has to be changed
right so that's unfair to make that
comparison the code is then struggling
and getting stuck in there and in this
case the central different but the
forward differences is having trouble
there but the central differencing gives
you pretty good approximation to the
problem and here's another example where
pretty much all the codes work well but
there's still something to be
recommended I think because suppose that
we were able to show that the
model-based trust region algorithm and
the question you can find a difference
quasi-newton method took about similar
number of function evaluations
you know the arithmetic cost of the two
approaches is so different right so I
can scale one so much there would be one
and also in some sense relatively easy
to implement okay so I will just finish
by pruning one result because something
I guess you were wondering ask as you
said well you described an outcome this
adaptive there can you prove a
convergence result for that algorithm to
a neighborhood well I don't have that
yet here right I think that we can be
done in the stencils
very important for that instead we're
gonna give Grover proof for a constant
step length algorithm in the presence of
noise just to see how the machinery
works so suppose you have a function
with additive noise twice differentiable
is the underlying function everything is
nice you have strong convexity suppose
that the eigenvalues of the quasi-newton
matrix are bounded otherwise you get
into this huge analysis and assume that
the noise is bounded absolutely right by
the way the hemming techniques for
estimating noise are assuming the noise
is iid so there and there possibility
there's several possibilities for that
no existe mean not to work correctly all
right so what can one prove for a fixed
step length there's a beta concern one
such that if the step length satisfy
those conditions L is a usual Lipschitz
constant then we get that the element
converges linearly to a neighborhood of
the solution so this is a linear convert
linear convergence we solved there's a
constant term here this is this is a
result of the form of net H and
bertsekas you converts to a neighborhood
of the solution where this quantity here
depends on the noise so here's the noise
system it enters there you converge
linearly to that to that point there
I wanted to make sure to stop early so
people could shoot me down and so I will
just make a couple of provocative
comments here to try to instigate more
attacks right
a number of iterations
this is the finite difference in our
business this is the finite difference
in volume this is the number of
iterations okay is the number of
iterations right
this is pretty normal right the starting
point the difference the gap of the
starting point
I read that every iteration is
functional relations for finite
difference
okay great
what constraints like even simple
constraints because for example even if
you could interval constraints your line
search may like it may not find the way
to the Armijo condition is going to be a
problem and by the way this is a comment
there now goes to non smooth
optimization right a non smooth
optimization what happens in my getting
interfered with that right so already
and reservation one of his students
wrote a paper on how to do quasi Newton
for non smooth problems when there's
bounds and also they're doing some
projection mechanisms so they were doing
that the Armijo line search in the right
subspace so you do that in two stages
and you identify things in such manners
right okay all right so what were my
provocative remarks you're going to do
optimization basis on function values
you're not going to do random search the
dimension is going to kill you right so
one of my concerns was dimension
thousand variables no way you're going
to do that people have developed pattern
search methods and coordinate its
descent is one of those right Maran wild
wrote a beautiful paper showing that the
katia type methods the powell katia type
modeled based methods are so much more
effective than pattern search methods if
you apply them to you know general the
derivative free optimization so the real
contender here are these models that cut
you have developed where you start you
know you evaluate functions you create a
linear model as you get more information
you start perusing your quadratic model
and you go that way and there's a nice
theory about them right now I've
observed all of this work fantastic work
and there are two things that always
worried me one of them is the cost and
the concept of doing a model by
interpolation and the other one is
really really it could be done in a
parallel way right so given those two
things and I thought I want to do the
model creation in a different way I
don't want to do it to interpolation
every every time I see interpolation I
see my hands tight so then my colleague
country has based
doing some convolutional net I saw other
people doing that and then when I
thought about this and when I talk about
this I thought about it for two years I
realized the only way I know how to
produce models that I can solve a no end
time is what quasi-newton updating and
they do good stuff so the motivation if
there was put all the effort then in
estimating the derivatives don't put so
much effort on the model put the effort
on estimating the derivatives and be
ready to fail there and to recover if
you have a difficulty there right so
then now we have interpolation models of
gradients versus interpolation of
function values BFGS is doing its magic
that we sort of understand but not quite
and and you can do the function
evaluations in parallel right so let's
have those mechanisms and the other
ingredient was just used noise
estimation in order to compute finite
differences EP and that that's it so I
thank myself again finishing on time
[Applause]